Bien !
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, dites-moi :
Quelle impression ces façons de parler vous ont faite ?
La première, du détachement peut-être ou c'est juste compliqué ?
"Qu'est-ce qu'il raconte ?"
L'autre, de l'inquiétude ?
Ou juste de l'engourdissement ?
De nouveau, la question était :
Comment impliquer les gens dans la résolution du réchauffement planétaire?
Pourquoi ces deux façons d'en parler ne marchent-elles pas ?
L'obstacle le plus important, s'agissant de traiter des perturbations climatiques,
repose entre vos oreilles.
Rassemblant un nombre grandissant de données psychologiques et sociologiques,
j'ai passé des années à étudier les cinq défenses intérieures
qui bloquent l'implication des gens.
Quand les gens entendent des nouvelles directes du climat,
la première défense surgit très rapidement :
la distance.
Quand on nous parle du climat, c'est quelque chose de loin dans l'espace -
la glace de l'Arctique, les ours polaires -
et loin dans le temps - l'an 2100.
C'est énorme et lent : des gigatonnes et des siècles.
Donc, ce n'est pas ici, ni maintenant.
C'est si loin de moi,
que cela semble être en dehors de mon cercle d'influence.
Donc, je me sens démuni à ce sujet :
je ne peux rien y faire.
Dans nos vies quotidiennes,
nous préférons, en majorité, penser à des choses plus proches
telles que notre travail, nos enfants,
combien de « J'aime » nous avons sur Facebook -
ça, c'est vraiment réel !
(Rires)
La défense suivante, c'est le catastrophisme.
Le changement de climat est portraituré comme une catastrophe imminente,
entraînant pertes, coûts et sacrifice.
Et cela nous fait peur.
Mais, la première peur passée,
mon cerveau souhaite rapidement éviter totalement ce sujet.
Après trente ans d'informations alarmantes sur le changement de climat,
plus de 80 % des articles de presse
continuent à utiliser le langage de la catastrophe.
Mais les gens s'habituent et ensuite,
ils se désensibilisent à l'utilisation excessive du catastrophisme.
Donc, bon nombre d'entre nous souffrons
d'une sorte de « fatigue de l’apocalypse »,
devenus ankylosés par un excès de « porno de la catastrophe ».
La troisième défense est la dissonance.
Quand ce que nous savons -
les carburants fossiles contribuent au réchauffement -
contredit nos actions - conduire, prendre l'avion, manger du bœuf -
alors, la-dite dissonance cognitive s'établit.
C'est ressenti comme un malaise intérieur.
Nous nous sentons hypocrites.
Pour se débarrasser de ce malaise,
notre cerveau commence à imaginer des justifications.
Donc je peux dire, par exemple :
« Mon voisin a une plus grosse voiture que moi »,
ou : « Changer de régime ne change rien si je suis le seul à le faire »,
ou je peux même vouloir douter de la climatologie elle-même
en disant : « De toute façon, le climat change sans arrêt. »
Ces justifications nous font nous sentir mieux,
mais, au mépris de ce que nous savons.
Ainsi, les comportements induisent-ils les attitudes.
Personnellement, ma dissonance cognitive fait surface
quand je reconnais que j'ai pris l'avion d'Oslo à New York, puis de retour à Oslo,
dans le but de parler...
... du climat ! (Rires)
Pendant quatorze minutes !
(Rires)
Cela m'incite à vouloir passer au démenti.
Quand nous gardons le silence,
ignorons ou ridiculisons les faits concernant les perturbations climatiques,
nous pouvons trouver un refuge intérieur contre la peur et la culpabilité.
Démentir ne vient pas vraiment d'un manque d'intelligence ou de savoir.
Non, démentir est un état d'esprit
dans lequel je suis au courant de certaines choses troublantes
mais je vis et j'agis comme si je ne le savais pas.
On peut appeler ça un genre de « double vie » :
savoir tout en ne sachant pas.
Souvent, c'est renforcé par les autres, ma famille ou ma communauté,
qui sont d'accord pour ne pas aborder ce sujet délicat.
Enfin, la dernière est l'identité.
Les activistes du climat, alarmés,
demandent aux gouvernements d'agir
soit par des régulations, ou par des taxes sur le carbone.
Mais, voyez ce qui arrive
quand des gens adhérant à des valeurs conservatrices, par exemple,
entendent un activiste dire que le gouvernement se doit de s'agrandir.
Dans les démocraties occidentales riches,
ils sont moins susceptibles de croire cette science.
Pourquoi donc ?
Eh bien, si j'adhère à des valeurs conservatrices,
je préfère probablement les grosses voitures et un petit gouvernement
plutôt que les petites voitures et un grand gouvernement.
Donc, quand la climatologie vient et dit :
« Le gouvernement devrait s'agrandir »,
je ne vais probablement pas faire beaucoup confiance à cette science.
C'est de cette manière que l'identité culturelle
commence à passer outre les faits.
Les valeurs se nourrissent de faits
et mon identité l'emporte sur la vérité, à chaque fois.
Maintenant que nous avons compris comment ces cinq « D » avortent toute implication,
comment pouvons-nous les dépasser ?
De nouvelles recherches montrent comment inverser ces cinq défenses
et les transformer en critères clés de succès
pour parler du climat de façon plus conviviale.
Et c'est là que ça devient vraiment excitant,
et que nous découvrons les cinq « S »,
les cinq solutions prouvées, pour ce qui fonctionne.
D'abord, nous pouvons changer « distance » en « social ».
Nous pouvons faire que le climat soit perçu comme personnel et urgent
en l'introduisant chez nous,
et ce, en répandant des normes sociales qui encouragent les solutions.
Si je crois que mes amis ou mes voisins: vous,
allez faire quelque chose, je vais le faire aussi.
C'est le cas, par exemple, des panneaux solaires sur les toits.
Ils se propagent d'un toit à un autre comme un virus.
C'est contagieux.
C'est le pouvoir du pair-à-pair qui crée la nouvelle norme.
Ensuite, nous pouvons changer « catastrophisme » en « solidarité ».
Au lieu de nous en prendre aux structures
telles que les désastres et les coûts,
nous pouvons redéfinir le climat comme une vraie question de santé humaine,
grâce à de délicieux burgers à base de plantes, par exemple,
bons pour vous et bons pour le climat.
Nous pouvons redéfinir le climat comme une question
de nouvelles opportunités technologiques, de sécurité et de nouveaux emplois.
Les métiers du solaire en effet, sont en plein développement.
Ils viennent de dépasser la barre des trois millions d'emplois.
La psychologie nous dit que pour créer de l'implication,
nous devrions mettre sur la balance,
trois formulations positives ou encourageantes
pour chaque mention de menace.
Ensuite, « dissonance » peut être transformée en actions plus simples.
Cela s'appelle : le Nudge.
L'idée, c'est qu'en améliorant l'architecture du choix,
nous pouvons rendre les conduites respectueuses du climat,
habituelles et pratiques.
Pour illustrer cela, prenons le gaspillage de nourriture.
Le gaspillage dans les buffets diminue grandement
si la taille de l'assiette ou de la boîte est légèrement réduite,
parce qu'une plus petite assiette paraît remplie
tandis qu'une grande boîte paraît à moitié vide,
donc nous en mettons plus.
Des petites assiettes font la différence dans le gaspillage de nourriture,
et il existe des centaines de nudges astucieux similaires.
L'idée, c'est que plus les nudges augmentent, plus la dissonance diminue.
Ensuite, nous pouvons transformer le « démenti »
en concevant des signaux visualisant nos progrès.
Nous pouvons fournir des retours motivants
pour évaluer notre façon de résoudre les problèmes.
Mettons, vous améliorez le bilan carbone de votre transport
ou supprimez les gaspillages d'énergie dans vos bâtiments.
Une application appelée Ducky vous permet de le faire partager.
Vous y enregistrez vos actions
et vous pouvez voir les progrès de votre équipe ou de votre compagnie.
Cela vous donne des signaux en temps réel.
Enfin, « l'identité ».
Nous pouvons changer l'identité par des histoires positives.
Notre cerveau aime les histoires.
Nous avons besoin de bonnes histoires sur notre but,
et plus d'histoires sur les héros et les héroïnes
de tous bords, qui font vraiment changer les choses.
J'ai la fierté de voir que ma ville natale, Oslo,
s'engage dans un voyage courageux pour rendre ses transports électriques,
que ce soit voitures, motos ou bus.
Une des personnes à la tête de cela est Christina Bu.
Elle dirige l'Association des véhicules électriques depuis des années
et elle s'est battue tous les jours.
Le Royaume Uni, la France, l'Inde, la Chine ont aussi annoncé leur plans
pour mettre fin à la vente de voitures au combustible fossile.
C'est énorme.
Nous pouvons voir à Oslo, l'enthousiasme des propriétaires de voitures électriques
qui racontent leurs histoires électriques à leurs amis et voisins,
les entraînant à leur suite.
Donc, nous avons achevé le cercle partant des histoires pour finir au social.
Des milliers d'informateurs sur le climat
commencent à utiliser, maintenant, ces solutions tout autour du monde.
Néanmoins, il est clair que les solutions individuelles
ne sont pas suffisantes à elles seules pour résoudre l'issue du climat,
mais elles construisent certainement un support de base plus solide
pour les politiques et les solutions qui le peuvent.
C'est pour cela qu'impliquer les gens est si crucial.
J'ai commencé cette conférence
en expérimentant avec vous deux façons d'informer sur le climat.
Il y en a également une troisième que je souhaite partager avec vous.
Elle redéfinit d'abord le climat lui-même
comme étant l'atmosphère dans laquelle nous vivons.
« Le climat n'est pas une abstraction,
un climat lointain, loin, très loin de nous.
Il s'agit de cet air qui nous entoure.
Cet air, vous pouvez le sentir ici aussi, dans cette salle,
l'air qui se déplace à cet instant dans vos narines.
Cet air est la peau de notre planète Terre.
Elle est étonnamment fine
comparée à la surface de la Terre et du cosmos dont elle nous protège,
beaucoup plus fine que la peau d'une pomme
en comparaison à son diamètre.
Il semble infini lorsque nous regardons le ciel
mais le bel air respirable a juste huit à onze kilomètres d'épaisseur,
une enveloppe fragile autour d'un énorme ballon.
A l'intérieur de cette membrane,
nous sommes tous intimement connectés.
Les respirations que vous venez de prendre
contiennent près de 400 000 atomes d'argon,
les mêmes que Gandhi a respiré durant sa vie.
Dans ce film fin, fluctuant et instable,
la vie toute entière est nourrie, protégée et maintenue.
Il isole et régule les températures
dans des proportions idéales pour l'eau et la vie telle que nous la connaissons.
Intermédiaires entre l'océan bleu et l'éternité noire,
les nuages transportent les milliards de tonnes d'eau
dont ont besoin les sols.
L'air remplit les rivières,
mélange les eaux,
arrose les forêts.
Dans les bizarreries du temps,
il y a de bonnes raisons de s'inquiéter et désespérer.
Pourtant, nous devrions d'abord nous attrister
sur l'état déplorable et les pertes d'aujourd'hui,
et ensuite, nous tourner vers le futur
avec des yeux pleins de larmes et de détermination. »
La nouvelle psychologie de l'action sur le climat
consiste à abandonner non pas la science,
mais les béquilles de l'abstraction et du catastrophisme
et choisir de raconter les nouvelles histoires.
Ce sont les histoires
sur la façon de réduire, d'inverser le réchauffement climatique.
Ce sont les histoires des mesures que nous prenons
en tant qu'individus, villes, compagnies, et organismes publics,
pour protéger l'atmosphère malgré la force des vents contraires.
Ce sont les histoires de nos initiatives
parce qu'elles nous ancrent
dans ce que nous sommes en tant qu'hommes:
des terriens à l'intérieur de cette atmosphère vibrante de vie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)